[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger
horn I know it's been a very long time
since the last episode of made on this
and how it's even been a very long time
since I've had any kind of decent upload
rate and for those of you who haven't
seen my frontier Expo flog I just want
to clarify I've been living in Japan for
the past three months as a part of an
exchange program which is really cool
and it's a really cool thing for my
University and I've been doing all kinds
of awesome things but I've basically
done barely any planet coaster in the
last three months and I haven't been
able to even finish a single video
in fact that's sort of what I'm trying
to achieve here so that's my poor
explanation for why my upload rate has
been so terrible recently and why I
actually haven't worked or why I
actually haven't made a video on Jaeger
horn in about three months that said
there are some funny repercussions for
this video in particular because I
started making this video in early
September when I had like a few hours to
play around with it and I just finished
it very recently so this has been
recorded over like three months and when
I started this the Halloween update
wasn't even out yet and when I ended
this it was just before the
one-point-four update even came out so
this is some old stuff and also I
haven't done a proper commentary in
about three months either so maybe I'm a
little bit out of it we'll see how I'll
handle this stuff but um yeah just so
you know that's basically what's going
on right now I'm sorry about me not
posting as much as I used to be and
really being out of the planet coaster
game practically because any of the
videos that I have been posting recently
I just sort of pinched or I just sort of
saved up over the summer vacation when I
was in Holland
so yeah basically don't [ __ ] home
recently
but hopefully and this is my very
hopeful sort of statement at the end of
this but it's not entirely promised
because I don't know so make it a
promise but hopefully I will pick it up
a little bit more I definitely don't
have as much time as I used to have in
Holland but um it should be a little bit
better than what it used to be I
definitely want to get back into the
game and just playing it a few times
sort of getting back into the swing of
things definitely made me want to play
it quite a bit more and of course the
one point for updates also had a bit of
a role to play in that recently as well
in any case let's actually talk about
this episode because I'm already
massively behind so I caught this
episode the Alpine Bridges
because in this episode I'll mostly be
working on four bridges and I know that
sounds like a really lame idea for a
theme of a video but I actually thought
it was a pretty handy sort of little box
to put this episode in and give it a
sort of neat little theme since these
bridges I think do actually quit play
quite a role in this whole area and they
all play a slightly different kind of
role I know that sounds very pretentious
but there there are very sort of
different bridges and how they work with
the rest of the area so this first
bridge obviously is a very traditional
stone bridge it's kind of like those
classical Alpine bridges or the Roman
aqueducts if you will and it's sort of
this mountain bridge that you very often
see between canyons and I kind of wanted
to do this because it made the the whole
scene for me with the station a little
bit stronger I know I'm running behind
here but I just wanted to keep talking
about this bridge while I'm more working
on the second one which isn't really as
interesting I think
but um yeah that stone bridge for me was
pretty important since it sort of
creates a force perspective in the sense
that it's a lot smaller than those
bridges would be in real life so it sort
of makes the whole scene a bit of a
miniature and makes it a little bit more
interesting than if it were just a
simple to scale wooden bridge which
would make the station look quite small
and also it has a very slight downward
slope because of course the coaster
track itself is downward slope but it
has a downward slope that goes away from
the path and it wasn't actually
something that I intended from the
beginning but as I built the bridge it
actually works out amazingly because
it's a kind of force perspective it
makes it seem as if the bridge is larger
than it really is because you know if
you're looking at something which is
higher than your vantage point and it
sort of despairs into the distance it
goes down in your view
and this bridge sort of has that same
effect going on but it's like made more
extreme by the fact that the bridge
actually does go down even though it
doesn't look that way from the path so
it sort of makes it look as if the
bridge is going further away than it
actually is which in turn makes the
station look like it's further away than
it actually is and it sort of makes the
whole scene a little bit larger which is
sort of helped by the fact that right
next to the path where you'll be looking
at the bridge the grass also goes down
so it really makes this whole tiny
little trench that the coaster goes
through sort of look like an actual
proper mountain pass which I guess sort
of hikes back to the whole idea of this
ride and then it's kind of like a
miniature railroad and I'm sort of using
the same ideas here but it's on a
slightly larger scale it's not quite on
the same scale as you know a real-life
alpine landscape but everything is sort
of a miniature version of them of their
real selves that doesn't so much count
for the second bridge here which is just
very simple it's just a way to sort of
incorporate this path into the hill
which is on the side of it and it also
kind of helps to make the train sort of
seemingly come out of this cave it
creates this very dark hole underneath
the path which i think is some very
interesting interaction and I think
should look pretty interesting when
you're walking over the paths that go
next to this bridge or when you're
walking over the bridge and you can see
that in the Train sort of come out from
this little tunnel that you have under
the path I think that's just a sort of
interesting play that I wanted to have
with the Train and the path here but you
know that makes everything sound a lot
better than it actually is it's in
reality is just a very simple bridge
that's not really as good as the other
ones in this episode but for me is still
very important because it works pretty
well in the whole scene that I'm trying
to set up here so here's I took a little
bit of a break and it's something that's
a little bit of a mandatory chore at
this point and made the catwalks
alongside the coast of track here I
wasn't entirely sure if I should have
them over here since this is like a turn
that goes up and you'd sort of reckon
you don't really need a catwalk that
and over here but in the end I did go
for it because for one it looks good but
also this turn is a little bit of a
problem it actually enters the final
brakes with a very slow speed to the
point where I actually put Drive tires
right at the beginning of the brake run
by making them block brakes instead of
regular brakes and in that sense I guess
it sort of makes sense to have catwalks
along this entire thing because it's
actually possible for the train to get
stalled at the top and you know whenever
a wheel wouldn't entirely work or
something when one of the tires doesn't
work then I guess this sort of can't
walk would actually come in quite handy
but yeah that's definitely one of the
more boring aspects of this coaster just
something that I need to get in here
right here is actually one of my
favorite points of this episode and it's
the roofed bridge so yeah you can see
that every single bridge building in
this video is a slightly different one
and I really just wanted to also have
some fun and try out different designs
so this one is inspired by some of the
Alpine bridges that I've personally seen
in the Alps in Europe which are these
bridges that they sometimes build over
rivers in the mountains which are often
slightly curved even though this one is
straights because obviously it's a cube
path and it would be really hard to make
this actually curved but they have these
these simple roofs over them it's just a
simple you know timber structure but
it's something and I quite liked and in
this sense I wanted to try it out as
well it also helps that it's another
excuse for me to put a spire on top of
something so yeah I'll be putting a
spire on top of this bridge as well so
we're just gonna have a whole load of
spires in this area maybe a little bit
overdone but in the end I actually
really liked the look that it has and it
goes very well with the station as well
and what it also sort of helps doing is
sort of splits up the two sight lines
that we have on the left side of the
station and on the right side of the
station because their sight line in the
middle wasn't really as interesting to
me and there's a lot of stuff in the way
so this roof just sort of make sure that
you don't really have much of a sight
line over here anyway it's more this
this sort of bridge that's drawing all
the attention and not
sightline to the station but on the left
of this bridge I think there's a pretty
good one from the the main path where
you look onto the stone bridge and on
the right side of this there is a pretty
good sight line from the other bridge
which is the last one that I work on in
this episode which is a little bit you
know earlier into the queue when you can
see the station and I think that one
works out very well as well but like
from Strader home straight ahead on this
path it doesn't really work that well
for me so I just figured I'd have enough
space to just fill this in with the roof
and in any case I don't think it really
you know it really sticks out too much
because it is right next to the bridge
of the coaster anyway which was another
tricky thing I sort of tried making it
in such a way that from one side you see
this bridge and like this is the focus
you see that that path with the roof
over its and the construction underneath
it but from the other side you barely
see any of this
you mostly just see the stone bridge
because this bridge is so much lower
than the bridge that the coaster runs
over so it actually gives a very
different look from both sides as well
which I thought was kind of interesting
and oh yeah the last reason that's gonna
you know not be as interesting as the
other ones but the last reason was
basically just that I wanted to try out
one of these kinds of bridges I've never
really done them like exactly as
detailed as this and doing every single
part of the timber structure and tiny
wooden posts and it's just a lot of fun
to do it the same goes for the roof it's
it's a very simple kind of roof but it's
made up of many different pieces and the
trick is really just to make sure that
you cut out all the pieces enough so you
don't get any z-fighting because if you
were to really make these all in exactly
the same spots there there would always
be a tiny bit of overlap in textures and
you'd get some weird sea fighting from
that and also it just makes them of
course look a lot a lot more realistic
if you actually have some tiny shadows
and it's highly tiny feeling of depth
between these roof tiles and finally I
also just wanted to change the colors a
little bit on them of course
seems you know that makes it sort of
look like every every shingle because
they're actually shingle are you know
it's slightly different I didn't
actually mention the final reason why
this roof is pretty handy it's not
entirely why I got the thing but it's
just very handy to have a cue with
something going over it in cases that
it's a hot day and you want to have some
shade from the Sun or when it's already
that rainy day when I have some shade
from the rain it's very common for
themed pikes to put some kind of cover
onto a cue so if you can actually theme
that cover and make it a part of the
environment instead of just putting up
some very cheap metal roofs or tents
like Six Flags would do then I think
you've got something quite good going
that can no work both functionally in a
practical sense and be something that's
nice to look at and that's always good
something that I haven't mentioned so
far yet though and that I think I should
talk about in this series is that you
should probably not do this if you're
planning to make any large park at all
this is one of the reasons why Jaeger
horn is just gonna be this one coaster
this tiny little area and why I'm not
gonna expand it even though it does seem
like it should be part overview Park and
I'm trying to make that way it's just
because groups like these and doing
detailing like this is you know using so
many more pieces than you theoretically
even should in blended coasters so it's
already legging up my game quite a lot
even though I don't have that much
scenery here and you know the more you
add these sort of roofs with all kinds
of separate pieces where the game has to
render a bunch of stuff that you really
don't see the more you start you know
ruining your gameplay for not really
important reasons just a tiny little
aesthetic difference between making a
roof yourself and just using one of the
roofs from the game which are fine
either way but I just want to have some
slightly different looks and that
slightly you know more more different
effects because one of the one of the
things that I like about this is that
you can actually make every single
shingle look
and just like a repeating texture and
the same goes for the sort of shadows
and overall dynamic lighting that you've
got coming here so now it comes to the
rock work and terraforming underneath
the ride I'm not entirely sure anymore
at what point I was recording this but I
think this was still part of the earlier
recordings it's really just the later
parts of recording this step I only
recorded more recently but it was still
kind of interesting because by now
Jaeger horn has been taking so much time
that every single time I open up my game
I had to sort of look back on what I was
making myself and try to learn for
myself on what I was doing and copy you
know the things that I was doing myself
which is you know just one of those
things to keep in mind with all of my
videos is that you only see the things
that I'm doing that actually turned out
to be something good and that didn't
turn out to be a huge mess and like
probably half my time in Jaeger horn is
just been you know fiddling with ideas
or trying out something and getting a
look that isn't entirely right and
another part is just looking at my own
stuff and trying to see how the hell I
did previous things after I've booted up
my game for like the first time in a
month so it's a it's a really sort of
weird slow process in that sense and I'm
just trying with the foliage and the
catwalks and like the terraforming
everywhere to get the same sort of look
throughout the ride in as well
and of course at some points the the
catwalks I'm trying to do this sort of
thing where do you see it with
rollercoasters with like wooden roller
coasters as well where there are like
little crossing spots where you're
supposed to cross the wooden where
you're supposed to cross the coaster
tracks and you've got like these beams
laid out over the coaster so that's also
what I've been doing over here and
whenever it sort of goes from catwalks
and one side of the coaster to Kant
walks on the other side I actually have
no idea what I'm gonna do with this
weird part of the track where it sort of
goes over the over the other part of the
track where it's like one big curved and
banked hill because it's horrible sort
of structure and a horrible shape to
even turn into a bridge so I have no
idea what I'm gonna do with that yet or
how many we're gonna put any catwalks on
that but um for now I'm just sort of
procrastinating on it and just working
on the rest of the area instead as for
this area I actually wanted to finish
this off with these tiny bushes and
rocks just to make sure that I could
take pictures and videos of these
bridges that I'm making in a sort of you
know finished environments usually for
me if I'm making something it really
helps to just make the general area
around that look more or less finished
as well because it just makes a huge
difference I know I always talk about
like foliage making a huge difference on
how certain things look and whenever I
make a building I like to just get a
basic amount of foliage around it just
so that it looks a little bit more
finished it always leaves me with a
slightly more satisfied feeling at the
end and it's just a better idea that you
can get of how your building is gonna
look in the end with the context of the
rest of the park around as well so
moving over to one of the other little
things that I did in between in this
episode as well I decided to make a
flower bed and for some reason instead
of just going with a regular edge or
curb by the way the curbs from one point
four are absolutely amazing I know I
don't really have like an update video
so I don't really have a dedicated time
and space to talk about these things but
then the curbs in the newer plate are
really handy and good in any case I'm
just making my own custom curbs here and
there's no need for those sins and the
guests can't walk through them but um I
wanted to get this like little rock
blocks look to it and the only way I
could do so was to actually make it out
of separate little items every single
time so yeah it's just one of those
cases where just to get a tiny bit more
detail I decide to get hundreds of more
objects than I actually need into the
game I do like the look of it though in
any case over here I'm trying to keep
this fence quite low it's probably too
low for American safety standards but I
think it should be fine in general
considering my Park might be probably
somewhere in Europe or something so um
yeah I wanted to keep this fence low
because obviously I want to have that
really cool small Vista of the bridge
with the station in the back there and
the same goes for the flowers in the
little planter then I've got going here
I'm gonna put some like flowers and
small shrubbery in there but everything
is just gonna stay quite low just to
keep that sort of sight line onto the
station in texts so yeah I support the
flowers themselves that's um some kind
of boring stuff that's not really any
specific pattern or anything I'm just
putting a bunch of different flowers in
different areas but what's become one of
my favorite things to do is just to take
some of the really small flowers some of
the ones that we've only been able to
recolor since recently and use those to
create large flower beds since it just
gives you you know much more control
over what the flower beds actually look
like instead of taking like those very
large rose bushes from the game which
also look quite good but they don't
really allow you to make that typical
flat flower bed that's like a large
flower bed made out of lots of very
small flowers basically
and yeah actually I'm even keeping the
lamps very low here anyway we're moving
on to the very final point of this video
which is the last bridge and this is a
bit of a weird one it's like a little
bit of a finicky bridge because it's
inspired by these old railroad bridges
which looking back is kind of weird
since it's actually a path it's
supporting a path here but I figured you
know in this area this would fit the
best since I want to keep this as open
and thin and subtle as possible and I
figured with this kind of bridge we can
actually achieve that so it really just
takes some wooden planks to support the
path and then there's a few wooden
supports underneath that which are all
just sort of really hammered into each
other it's not really the most you know
functional looking structure ever but
this is a theme park anyway and this
stuff is reinforced anyway and there's
probably some steel beneath all of that
so I'm fine with this I just wanted this
to look a little bit finicky you know
like something that's not quite
something to be used very often and that
just sort of runs through the landscape
like an old railroad train and how I
just wanted to try another type of
bridge as well would be super boring if
every bridge look the same see how
that's basically what I'm trying to do
here and you can tell I've got the
Halloween update at this point because
I'm working with those smaller wooden
pieces which I absolutely love
I actually quite liked the Halloween
update as well yeah I'm talking about
the Halloween update a month later
because I didn't really have the
opportunity to earlier and yeah I was
actually quite a fan of its a lot of
good scenery in there which can be used
for amazing detailing so I'm always glad
when there's you know a larger amount of
pieces to work with because with every
little bits that the piece count
continues to go up in Planet Coast like
the amount of possibilities that you
have pretty much go up much more because
there are so many more like combinations
that you can make with the new items and
especially because the Halloween updates
brought all of these wall decorations
and new posts
like tiny decorations that you can you
know decorate posts and walls with I
thought that was very good sort of first
time or addition to the scenery of the
game and you know you can even use it
for a wooden bridge in an alpine park so
I'm mostly glad actually with the
Halloween updates because of the non
Halloween uses that you can have for the
Halloween objects in any case that's
just about it for this video I'll be
just finishing off with a small part
leaning up to the cue speaking of which
the cue is the topic for the next video
I'm not entirely sure how I'm gonna take
it yet but I'll be adding all the
scenery around that's and finishing up
the cue in the next episode so I hope
you guys enjoyed this video and I hope
to see you guys hopefully soon in the
next one
[Music]